[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream q a
section number 70 what did we decide
two 72 72 42 of course yep
it's multiple of nine yes that's all
72 trombones no really
you could have 72 trombones ah you could
yes it is a plausible number of
trombones
leading some big parade yep yes okay
um we are going to start with a few
questions from last episode from 71
answer a question from the discord
server and
then man there are a lot of good
questions this week so we're going to
miss
even more of the good questions than we
usually do
uh let's just launch right into it
actually i made an
error during our initial podcast can i
just say
i should have mentioned the earshod
mongi podcast that people
should check out which is excellent 100
conversations
that just went uh you just posted that
last night right so it's it's just been
up briefly
just been up briefly but people are
loving it great um so in any case
check it out she's fabulous she is
really marvelous yeah
okay um first question from last week
uh pdxer so this starts with a bunch of
of acronyms but they all
are meaningful pdx are here hi that's
someone from portland lgbtq poc raising
kids
uh we don't believe in the hostile
rhetoric heard or taught here
i'm afraid kids raised with these views
will will rebel in 10 to 20 years and
join identitarian movements
what are your thoughts we love the show
so i love hearing from people in
portland we've been hearing from
for more and more and it just it's it's
heartening
yeah and and just i love it and also um
you know i also believe that even
many many more people than are than
we're hearing from or who are saying it
out loud
also don't like the hostile rhetoric uh
and uh i think that that will be that
will be a response to joint identitarian
movements in part
because the a lot of the woke stuff is
effectively identitarian i mean that's
what it is
it's just you know anti-racism is
identitarian
yes anti-racism turns out to be racist
and
it claims to be racist for a good cause
many of us don't believe that there is
such a thing as racist for a good cause
yeah um but in any case
yeah i i made the argument uh quite some
time ago i guess it would have been
2018 or 19 that this uh that we were
effectively going to conjure
um the exact demon that is being falsely
alleged was
driving whites into identitarian uh
thinking um and this is this is the same
so yes i think it is a real danger
and frankly uh all the folks pushing
this how dare they play with us it's not
their fire to play with
and um they are putting us all at risk
over nonsense notions
many of which are um the sort that could
be easily dismissed
in a matter of minutes given reasonable
people
who have room to say uh what's true and
extrapolate from it yep
and they're going to create a an enemy
whose strength is
the likes of which they have been
claiming they were fighting from the
beginning
yep absolutely okay next question
while our cats go to town on the cream
in the background
honest question why do people hate the
idea of decolonizing
certain aspects of education is it the
term decolonize
indigenous people mainly use stories to
educate about morals etc even engaged in
rudimentary science
is it fear of change
well i will say for my part i resent the
idea of decolonization because
it is effectively um
a nonsense claim where it is deployed i
don't
object to the idea that there might be
certain aspects of the way
we educate that could be
disaster averted that could be improved
in other words like everything else in
this landscape
you know the terms are
garbage by virtue of the way they're
being used they're not inherently
garbage
is there something to the postmodern
understanding
that it is impossible to escape
our predispositions
no of course that's true but um you
can't extrapolate it into a world view
you can recognize
that it's a hazard and do something
about it is there something that we
could legitimately call anti-racism
that would be worth engaging in yes but
we can't now because anti-racism
turns into a manipulative tactic um
is there something we could call white
fragility um
you know sure of course but of course
the way white fragility is deployed
it's a nonsense accusation designed to
prevent people from
being skeptical of claims that they
should be skeptical of so
uh decolonize sure is there a legitimate
version that could exist yes but the
version that we see
is simply uh you know i don't know a
talisman or something
that is um being wielded in lieu of an
argument
and yes um i agree what do you do with
it
i agree the cancel
so um not last week but i guess two
weeks ago we focused on dr
seuss and so this question from last
week says the council cult targeting dr
seuss
caused increased demand and sales for
that once mild bigot
a beautiful irony or a fiendish plan
does woke idiotology mean to make itself
look ridiculous thus fueling sense
love darkhorse um
yeah a i i don't think it was a plan b
it could be a plan but really
what that's just why you said that
well yeah i mean the point is you know
does it change anything if it is
no and in this case because it was the
publisher the seuss foundation or
whatever who said
um you know apparently in response to
pressure from
from wokes um to
stop publication of what was it six six
of the books
that could have been a hoped for you
know
results maybe um i i would be surprised
if
if soos needs a a pr bump but
yeah but i mean all of these things are
demonstrations of power
right yeah how much power do you have to
have to get a publisher to voluntarily
pull
books uh from a wildly popular author
out of the catalog a lot of power
does it matter that it was mostly
obscure books
no the point is they're demonstrating
power and
um i'm not sure what else to make of it
other than
this movement has a tremendous amount of
power and they affect things
uh when they can and they've targeted
everything so
um so yes i i'm a
i'd like to see some evidence if there's
any that suggests that this was
somebody's marketing campaign i don't
think that's what it was
um but it's beside the point yeah
movement has a tremendous amount of
power and
it's wielding it yep i agree so
we actually had a question from last
week
about i will butcher his name gert
vandenbosch
dutch phd virologist says vaccinating
during a pandemic would make coven 19
much much worse due to selective
immunoscape what are your thoughts on
this hugs to both of you i just wanted
to
so we actually had two more questions
today do you think
dr bosh has appealed to immediately and
completely stop all covered vaccines
worldwide as well advised
dhp rocks and then hi is it true you're
ending in five weeks
if so thank you very much for the sandy
provide during horrendously dark time
also are you worried about immune escape
as a result of vaccination during
pandemic be well
um so i feel like we addressed all of
these in the first hour but
um presumably these questions came in
before that happened so no we're not
ending in five weeks
and um and
you know it's complicated but we talked
about we talked about that yep before
so from the discord this week we have um
having a lot of idle dispossessed young
men around tends to have a net negative
effect on a society
what can or should we do to steer them
away from the path of desperation
think incel stuff political and
religious extremism sexual another
violence porn addiction etc
yeah uh we do big is a huge question
yeah it's an important one
um but so we're going to do a tiny
little bit here and then we should be
coming back to this we've
we talked about this a little bit in in
our book which it's still months away
but
and we we in effect talk around this
question all the time
right um i would say
we have a basic problem we have several
layers of problem we have a novelty
problem which is that we keep
introducing novel phenomena and
not anticipating that it's going to
cause disaster and this is
a major disaster but it is embedded in a
larger
a larger issue there is a motivational
problem based originally
in the invention of birth control which
i think birth control
is a net positive but it has huge
implications for social systems
that we did not properly anticipate and
we are now
decades many decades down the road and
the incentive structure is complete
nonsense in part because of us
the idea that any sort of um
self-limitation in the sexual landscape
is
really oppression and that basically the
height of sophistication as anything
goes when it's not true
so um and this is of course where jordan
peterson got into such trouble years ago
by
invoking the admittedly clumsy term
enforced monogamy
when in fact we come from a culture that
has a
legal uh legal prohibition against
poligini
also to the degree that there is social
enforcement of monogamy
in both humans and in other species it's
the females who are doing the enforcing
um they're you know to the extent that
there are winners from polygeny which is
the particular manifestation of polygamy
which is usually what people
when they're talking about humans say
the winners are the very very very few
males who actually end up with multiple
female mates
and you can also argue that they're not
winning everything they think they're
winning but
all the males who are therefore left
unmated and all
the females who are left um
with less uh you know child care and
partnership
and everything else and the children
themselves
all lose and this is actually i just i
happened to be doing research
yesterday on um the
health effects on children of mating
systems in
other human cultures basically comparing
monogamous cultures to polygenous
cultures and
um you know under polygonally children
fare less well
they have um they have lower life
expectancy and worse health health
outcomes so
um you know all of the hubbub about you
know
enforced monogamy who does he think he
is men always trying to enforce monogamy
on women like
nope it's been the other way around and
you know luckily for women most men are
also
interested in that because um because
it's basic it's better for almost
everyone the only people for whom it's
not better than
in a coherent system um of polygeny
uh is a very few men and this sort of
polyamorous
um promiscuous is the term of art uh in
in evolutionary biology free for all um
doesn't work for anyone long term
yeah it's it's a really bad way to run a
society it may be a good way to generate
an
army unfortunately so we should look out
for this as a
as a hazard yeah and i would also just
point out the thing that we
we've said multiple times which is
you'll find monogamy
is very common in birds monogamy is
never perfect in any species in which we
look at it but
it is something like 85 percent of bird
species show at least
seasonal within season monogamy and many
life long
and in mammals it's 15 and some clades
even less and the implication of this
i think that might even be high i don't
know um
i think it's 15 across mammals and it's
lower in bats and higher and some other
things but it doesn't doesn't much
matter
yeah i know bats but the point is
why are these numbers so far off of each
other why are birds so much more prone
to monogamous monogamy and the answer is
really interesting
the answer is that for physiological
reasons
the birds are more certain of their own
paternity male birds are in a much
better position to know
that hatchlings are theirs
than mammals because mammal pregnancy
separates
sex from birth in a way that males can't
track what's happened
weeks months earlier and so the point is
when males have high certainty of
paternity
they are selected to favor investment in
mates and offspring and so at least
opens the door for the possibility in a
way that the door isn't really even
open absent high certainty fraternity
well it's
open but the problem is the danger of
cuckoldry is so
uh massive that selection favors
males to abandon so they don't get
caught in that trap and so
anyway you want to see more monogamy
which you should because the benefits to
it are
so many and at every different scale
from the individual scale up through the
societal scale
what is the answer a higher degree of
certainty of paternity is what causes
males to be in that frame of mind
so anyway interesting puzzle yeah
so we didn't really answer the question
at all but we'll keep talking about this
i thought we did um what can or should
we do to steer them away from the path
of desperation
yeah so that was the actual question i
think we should i think we should move
on for now
um that said apparently this question
has been coming up a lot in the discord
so i i do think we should return to it
we just
we will end up talking forever about
this yep if we
if we stick to it right now uh what is
your take on the mrna vaccines versus
johnson johnson
if offered one tomorrow would you take
it assume that demand is greater than
supply so public health is not an issue
this is only a private health question
so thanks for all you do i appreciate
the the nuance in that question as well
that it you know it takes the public
health question off the table
um uh we haven't talked about this
recently
uh i would far prefer
johnson johnson to mrna and
um i am glad that i'm not in a position
to have to decide whether or not
i um will take it yet because um
i'd rather not yet and it's not on offer
yeah i would say unfortunately
delay is valuable because the problem
with all of these vaccines is how little
we know about
what they do i will say anecdotally i
hear
uh from a large number of people who are
in a position to give first-person
reports
very scary stuff about uh side effects
that have happened which
may not you don't know anyone who's had
the jnj right no this is just
uh madonna um but the point is
lots of stuff that you would you know i
don't think i have
heard of anybody who said anything that
yet looks like a permanent
uh harm but that the
number of things that appear to happen
uh in the immediate aftermath of getting
these vaccines is substantial
and the nature of the symptoms is
surprising and so the question is you
know as we
pointed out at the beginning we don't
know and we're intervening in a complex
system and you should expect things you
didn't expect to emerge
because of the nature of that system yep
and i
i uh i still think johnson johnson and
astrazeneca we didn't talk about it
today but i think the
the blood clotting stuff was a false
flag not that it didn't happen but that
it was
um unnaturally high as a result of the
vaccine seems likely to have been
not the case so you don't want false
light you mean false alarm
false alarm yes um oh false alarm isn't
quite right either that like
the idea that this um meant that the
vaccine was dangerous in this way
um i i think i i think was not was not
borne out by the actual evidence
so i still would prefer one of the dna
vaccines to one of the mrna vaccines
but because johnson johnson has been
around even less time the moderna and
pfizer
i'd like for it to have been around more
as much more time as possible before
um i myself end up having it and for you
know because of concerns about long-term
health effects
for those who have uh only recently come
to this conversation i would just say
the
part of the problem too is that we have
a massive vaccination effort
and no evidence about truly long-term
effects and even a delay of
months or years doesn't buy you insight
into what it does
20 years down the road right
what do you think is the most likely
coveted scenario going forward
besides vaccines work and it goes away
within the year as everybody gets
vaccines in other words where is the
risk and how do we spot it
um i actually
felt and i it was hard it's hard to
separate out
my assessment from my hope um but it
really
felt even before the vaccines were being
rolled out that we were going to end up
with this thing becoming endemic in the
population
and losing virulence and becoming one of
these chromoviruses that circulates and
kids get exposed to
and like they do for colds and that it
would
become less and less of a deal
i still hope that's a possibility i
don't know where to put the
probabilities at
well i would say the details of that
scenario
matter a lot and there's one way in
which i think that's a horrifying
scenario
and that the you know effectively adding
another influenza
um influence i said called well i know
but
within that it becoming endemic and us
being regularly uh infected by it
could potentially be a disaster or it
could you know descend into a level of
virulence where it would be
a nuisance still a huge setback but
nonetheless
uh it could be a tolerable one i think
there's a possibility
that the vaccine as ill-advised
as uh launching into a massive vaccine
vaccination campaign uh that is not
evolutionarily well
thought out is it's actually possible
that this could work
and that the um escapees will have
downsides associated with them
evolutionarily that will what kind of
escapees are talking about virus
virus virus escaping susceptibility but
i think it's
actually very likely that what happens
is that the arms race produces the
natural
uh counterpart on our side which is that
you know we will be generating vaccines
rapidly it will be escaping and we will
be chasing the virus
and um we will learn a lot about
the consequences of repeated vaccination
um so anyway there are a lot of
scenarios and i would say many
possibilities are open here including
presumably ones we haven't thought of
yep um but i'm you know
cross your fingers that uh this
vaccination campaign and there are ways
in which
if it makes any sense it hasn't been
explained to us how it does
the vaccinating of people who've had
covid still doesn't make any sense to me
right and it's a lot of people so why
are we exposing them to the hazard of a
vaccine we know nothing about the
long-term implications of that
seems indefensible yep but um
i guess we'll see yep what are the
evolutionary implications of showering
every day
not being able to shower while camping
in nature doesn't feel as dirty
as if you skip it when you're in the
city are we the urban ling's too
pureld is there any compromise
yes we're too purelled and it's it's
hard
it's hard to stop doing it when you're
when you're
interacting with other people who have
the same expectations of
of sort of smell and cleanliness
yep um i mean i think the implications
are
many some of them are positive and many
of them are presumably negative
there's temperature questions is it good
for you to
you know to jack the external
temperature the way
a hot shower does maybe it's neutral
right maybe it just takes the burden off
the caloric burning
momentarily who knows
it may be that it's related to anomalous
stuff like
kids getting acne just changing the
ecology of what's on the skin
treating this otherwise evolutionarily
bizarre
condition in us moderns
so that isn't necessarily about
showering but specifically these
injunctions you know wash your face
every day twice a day like wash your
face really
you sure sure about that like if you
know you've got stuff on your face you
need to clean that [ __ ] off
but that in particular has always struck
me as like
it's not at all clear to me that soap
belongs on your face ever
yeah well there are all kinds of
interesting questions too about like
brushing your teeth and what the natural
ecology of the mouth would be but then
on the other hand um it is also possible
that even something evolutionarily novel
like
showering or brushing the teeth might be
a positive compensation for
other novelty factors in other words
novel diet and novel population density
might cause you to behave differently um
with respect to these things than you
would in a natural situation
you could make a similar argument for
deodorant
in other words you know we're supposed
to stink a bit and it
carries information but we're not
supposed to be indoors packed together
the way we
offer them you know fabric against our
skin as well which is going to uh
maintain the level of of sweat on you as
opposed to having it disperse
yeah yeah so anyway uh good question and
yeah yes there are bound to be many
implications
yeah okay let's see
heterosexuality is obviously genetic and
ancient for reproduction
i can see so-called sexual preference
being fixed from birth to death in some
or even most humans but on what basis
can we say it's immutable in all humans
rather than being malleable over time
how much of said change would be down to
nature versus nurture being hetero used
to be natural until we observed other
gay animals
what about fluid preference and identity
um so there's a lot to be said on this
topic
i will say i do think sexual preference
is actually quite flexible in women and
for good reason right in other words
female homosexuality as a
hedge against the fluctuation in the
availability of males due to things like
warfare and you know potentially disease
given that males are more
physiologically fragile
is makes perfect sense and so
um in short why should any female
who is capable of producing and raising
offspring
ever choose not to by virtue of the fact
that there is no
mate available given that a male can
produce an arbitrarily large number of
gametes there's no reason so
females teaming up to
play maternal roles to raise children
i think will have been a common
compensation
male homosexuality tends to be obligate
rather than facultative
well i was going to point to um douglas
murray's
chapter on gay in the madness of crowds
is actually
um the whole book is terrific and you of
course had him you've had him
on twice and once in both in the wake of
the publication
maybe or just no once uh once was right
on his book tour and the other was when
he came through portland that's right so
both
after the book was published but um the
first time you spoke with him
was right after it was published and um
his chapter on gay you know he he is a
gay man
and his exploration in that of whether
if
why we have accepted why we have been
told that we must and
pretty much widespread acceptance of
sexual orientation is what you're born
with and that and there will never be
any effect from
environment um is actually the first
time i've seen
i've seen that kind of argument
explicitly with regard to
to male homosexuality and he does he
does a
terrific job of it i recommend that for
um person asking this question
uh in the interest of not creating
confusion though i am not arguing that
it is not
development a developmental consequence
i believe it is highly likely to be
what i don't think it is is facultative
so
that is to say so he argues for he
argues for the possibility of both
and there may be there may be you know
i'd be stupid to say
not at all faculty but i would say
facultative being the opposite of
obligate
if something is obligated always happens
if it's facultative there's
developmental choices to be right and in
fact uh
extreme situations like prison do seem
to indicate
some degree of flexibility just based on
who's available
but um the question is is the parameter
set to flip over a lifetime
given consistent circumstances or
relatively consistent circumstances
much less so in males than females i
believe the data reflect that
and that it makes a good deal of sense
that it should um
but anyway uh like that yep
after richard dawkins the selfish gene
what other book from him would you
recommend that complements really well
that great title my
my other favorite is always the
ancestors tale
his next book was the extended phenotype
and it's his favorite book
i have taught with it and it did not
strike me as
as as important um you know it
introduces
an an important idea but i think
ancestors tale
um gives you sort of the macro
evolutionary side of things that selfish
gene goes into the micro
um side really extensively and you're
also a fan of is it the god delusion
no no no i'm sorry i'm just a fan of it
no no i'm just seeing what you've got on
your shelf over here it's climbing
mountain problems
the god illusion is one that's shining
at me okay
it's not a good one it's good yeah until
the point which yeah it goes off the
rails sorry
um yeah yes the thing about extended
phenotypes is probably the part of
extended phenotype that you really need
is actually in modern versions
of the selfish gene it's like chapter
12. um
he didn't add he didn't add that uh
maybe he didn't add it
maybe it's in there from the beginning
but um it is in there
nonetheless the idea is there so i don't
i'm not sure you're right about this you
know memes are in chapter 12 but i think
extent
okay no anyway you got selfish gene
there too
um okay while you're looking it up
um perhaps i will move on to the next
question sure can you can you listen as
you're
i can't open that up hi superheroes this
one begins
is the pink in himalayan rock salt the
same pink that is in prawns and
therefore flamingos
why pink is it one or a combination of
minerals
i once went orange working in juice bar
with too much carrot
that does happen yeah that does happen
um i don't know the answer to this
uh i i it's it's quite possible because
like
the the stuff in the mountains is
ancient sea floor like that himalayas
were
um the part of the the floor of the
great tethys sea i guess or
maybe it was already the indian ocean as
india cruised north from
uh gondwana and hit hit asia and formed
the himalayas
um and so you know may may well be the
same thing i don't actually know what it
is it's a copper maybe it's
possibly copper uh i don't know you
don't know
i don't know yeah i know it's not
flamingos if that was the question
flamingo's in the salt
yes great what did you find
unfortunately it's not clear i think
it's going to be chapter uh
12 or 13 but where you where you think
he actually talks about extended fantasy
yeah he does
he clearly does uh next question man it
is pouring here at the moment pouring
wow they just uh spring in the bizarre
northwest is always
the old man has apnea
what are your thoughts on soft sex work
like only fans i find its implications
extremely concerning for both the male
buyers and female sellers
yeah so do i i i find the implications
extremely
concerning as well knowing almost
nothing about what's going on there or
what it is
all right i have a different take
slightly okay which is it's
very concerning except it depends what
you're comparing it
to right if you're going to compare only
fans to
pornhub probably it's a huge step in the
right direction
um but if you're going to compare it to
a healthy society with
a reasonable view of sex then it's
appalling yep
um yeah so it's it's not all relative
but you can do a relative analysis here
and should yeah so
yeah in the index we find extended
phenotype here
so he does
appear to bring it up a couple times at
the end of the book as you said
as i said as you said i am the reliable
narrator
sometimes sometimes this time i'm the
semi-reliable narrator you've chosen to
be reliable this time and the fact that
you
you're only facultatively reliable makes
you unreliable
it's chapter 13. i was facultative
and tenured
you were facultatively 10 you're just
what you were oh okay
facultatively tenured i actually yeah
that's like we were both we were yeah we
thought facultatively tenured that
we had these yeah professor and exile
should become facultatively
tenured yep yeah okay
uh will you two explain the simplest
layman terms why different species have
different lifespans
why is a 15 year old dog as decrepit as
a 100 year old man is there any chance
we can extend our lifespans
um i'm going to let you do this one all
right i'm on it facultatively
formerly faculty tenured brett weinstein
will take on this question of lifespan
excellent um so life's so
it's like this ideally you'd live an
infinite
period of time because an infinite
period of time gives you more
opportunity to make more offspring and
offspring are an important part of the
equation of fitness
okay just take that as a given of the
question however
there are lots of things in the world
that will kill you right and
because there are lots of things in the
world that will kill you if you imagine
a thousand people born in a given year
in which none of them age there will
come a year down the road at which none
of them are left due to all of the
accidents that you would encounter
what that means is that the number of
individuals you imagine a pathology
that afflicts individuals at
100 years past birth a lot of people
will not have lived to have seen it
because they will have died in accidents
before then so
its negative effect on the species will
be much smaller than something that has
an equivalently bad effect at 50 years
now we can extend that analysis out and
we can say
something that would kill you dead at
a million years has no negative effect
because nobody lives that long
so selection runs into a world in which
without any aging without any senescence
nobody would survive indefinitely and
the later a pathology happens
the less bad it is because lots of
people don't live to suffer from it
so what that means is that here's the
tricky part
when a gene does two things it
uh and when the late one is bad the
later that late one happens the less the
negative consequence is the more likely
selection is to include
you're looking at me like i'm not giving
this in layman terms which is
well but you're also not answering the
question but you're talking about
senescence but not different lifespans
right but so to finish the explanation
selection will favor genes that have a
good early effect and a late bad effect
um because the late life counts less
than the early life since everybody's
around for early life and fewer and
fewer individuals are around for the
late life
what this means is this counts less
there are fewer late lifes
per if you if you if for everything in
the population
you have a certain number of early lives
and a certain number of late lives and
you put all those early lives and late
lives into a bin
you have more early lives than late
lives simply because the early lives
come first
yes yeah so counts less is just like a
statistical
counts less in uh selective terms
selection sees it less clearly
okay now that's the background add into
that
the question of a creature that exists
how much less does selection see late
life
in creature a versus creature b now
let's compare two creatures like a mouse
and a bat of similar size
okay mouth and a bat a mouse and a bat
of similar size both fit into the mouths
of the same kinds of predators
but the mouse is much more susceptible
to being preyed upon because when
one of those predators happens onto it
it can't fly away
right so that means that a lot more bats
given a certain number of encounters
with bad stuff
right a lot more bats live to see their
next year
because they have a defense against
predation that the mice don't which is
flying away
we could make this demographically
that's true the demographically
if you get to i'm just going to make up
numbers here if you get to month
one of age as a bat you're very much
very likely to reach year five and if
you get to month one
as a mouse you aren't particularly
likely to
get to year five yes that's true
immortality at every ensuing month
beyond the
early risks of being a tiny thing are
much lower for
a volant mammal of similar size right so
there's a pattern
the bigger the animal you are the longer
life span tends to be
but within a given size animals that fly
outlive animals that don't fly animals
that are toxic
outlive animals that are not animals
that have a shell outlive animals that
don't
so there are a bunch of things that can
make you safer right
also things like you live on an island
where your predators don't happen to be
versus you live on the mainland where
they're common so
i'll go ahead do soft-shell turtles have
uh shorter lifespans than their
conscience their their closest relatives
i don't know but in this case we've got
a confound which is
are they soft-shelled because they
evolved for a niche in which the
predators don't exist in which case you
wouldn't expect them to live a shorter
life because they're
immune for other reasons but in any case
the point is
a mouse in the wild given the ability to
live out its life and die
of an old age pathology might live three
or four years
longer actually than a lab mouse or a
pet store mouse
however a bat of similar size in many
species can live to be
decades old in fact there are examples
of
bats that have been recaptured after 30
years in the wild small microbats
so the point is the extrinsic risk
the hazards in the environment the more
intense they
are the greater the bias towards
borrowing from the ability to live a
long time
in order to be very vigorous when you're
young and the
reduction in those hazards either
because of where you live or because you
have the characteristics to resist it
that results in selection seeing the
late life much more effectively and
therefore biasing in the direction of
giving you the possibility of living
longer and reproducing longer
so that's the basic landscape
dogs versus people right so well so
there's a question
dogs um are
well dogs have a wide range well there's
another pattern that has to do with dogs
well there's also there's also a body
size thing which you didn't talk about
to get there
like this is not a lecture we we really
need to get through a lot more questions
so we need to cut it's a general body
size pattern all else being equal bigger
animals
outlive smaller animals however within
the species variation goes the other
direction
smaller dogs tend to outlive larger dogs
so there's a question about what what
dogs we're talking about
and that's true for within a species
humans as well
and so uh this is part of what explains
the sex differential
in lifespan which is that women on
average being smaller than men on
average tend to have longer lifespans
right and there's a question about so
within species in between species the um
the pattern reverses pattern reverses
which is a very interesting fact
so let's just cap this off that's a
bunch of information that is relevant to
your question lifespan is a response to
the hazards that exist to you in the
world and what selection does in
response to them
and then the question about is there
anything that we can do about lifespan
and the answer is yes and no okay we
have
been fantastically successful at
increasing average lifespan
that also means that we have gotten
really good at making people
younger at more advanced ages right so
you can do things
at 60 and 70 that somebody 25 30 years
ago
might have only been able to do at 50.
so we're really good at this right but
we have not been good at
at all have made literally no gains as
far as we are aware is extending
maximum lifespan and that is a very
dubious prospect
even to the extent that we might come up
with spectacular things
there are limits that make it very
unlikely that a the life that we can
give you extending that number is going
to be very desirable in other words what
if we could make you
uh live to 130 but we didn't weren't
able to do anything about senility
right that would be an ugly life so the
number's right about at 120
right yeah right in the neighborhood of
120 maximum human life
right but basically the short answer is
enjoy it while you're here
and don't listen to the people who think
that we're right around the corner from
extending maximum lifespan because
they're trying to get their grants
funded
okay physics professor here the time
between equinoxes during winter
is only about three percent shorter than
during summer due to the earth having a
nearly circular orbit
so i'm right about the principle but the
nearly circular orbit means that in
practice it doesn't matter a great deal
that's
beautiful thank you thank you thank you
this morning i dreamt i was hanging out
with brett
i was late for work and had to leave he
was disappointed because he wanted to
shoot some hoops
i don't even know if he plays basketball
but i certainly don't
but i woke feel that's him senses this
person saying i don't know if he plays
basketball but i certainly don't
but i awoke feeling disappointed with a
question the two of you have affected
the hearts minds and now subconscious of
so many
how often do you discuss your tremendous
reach and can you now look at the trauma
of evergreen as a blessing
um yeah that's a complex question uh i
i don't i will certainly play hoops but
not well um so that settles that that
wasn't the question
um was evergreen a blessing i think
uh net net i'd have to say
for us it was but yeah and
and given what the school has continued
to do right sure
we were living on borrowed time for at
least a year as it was
yeah so um i'll put it to you this way
i'm happy with what we're doing
i'm not happy with what has happened to
our security
right but that's really the place that
except as
you know see earlier point we were
apparently without knowing it we were
facultatively tenured
all along right we thought we had
obligate tenure
and we were actually facultatively
tenured oops
yeah are bad i don't think so it turns
out that when your institution
goes woke and disloyal on you um the
security that you thought you had which
is one of the big
benefits of being in the system ain't
worth anything
to his credit eric pointed this out uh
before evergreen had gone
upside down oh yeah like specifically
this about tenure
yeah yeah it didn't look like a secure
job
to him he was right yeah and what can
you do when he's right he's right
yeah um why do we prefer unhealthy food
for healthy food
also did the tongue evolve to give
preference to certain flavors found in
higher calorie foods or is it a culture
a thing and you could teach a newborn to
prefer broccoli over cake
um
it's not it's neither in the tongue nor
the culture
per se you know it's there's there's
mechanistic stuff in the tongue and
there's cultural preferences for
certain kinds of food in some places and
you know the east asian cuisines don't
tend to have nearly as much sugar
as uh as say you know french cuisine
which isn't sugar rich in a lot of
places but obviously they've got a
patisserie
um uh culture that um exists less so
in say japanese cuisine um but
you know it's the the simplest answer
and this i feel like again we should
spend many episodes talking about food
and we have
one chapter in our in our book on it um
is simply about you know the sort of the
least interesting level of answer here
is um that we are craving the things
that were rare in our ancestral
environment and which are no longer rare
and why aren't they rare anymore
precisely because we crave them and so
corporations can make money off of
making them available and charging us to
access them
yep so the point is it's not that these
are the unhealthy things it's that
the fact that we did not evolve to limit
our desire for them because there was no
need the world limited our desire for
them
right um means that we eat too much of
them
and that that does bad things to our
physiology
is it wise to pursue a relationship that
is hindered by the atlantic ocean and
closed borders
i met a woman from france online she
shares my worldview and enjoys authors
that were formative in my thinking
here in oklahoma where i am my worldview
makes me a black sheep
um i would say
there is no basis for
questioning when you found the right
person on the basic
the basis of geographical undesirability
either this is the right person
and your desire to be with them will
eventually overcome
all of these obstacles and it will be
all the sweeter when it does
or it's going to turn out that your mind
is fooling you and
this will no longer seem so smart and
you'll
both move on and and that but to the
extent that your
your mind is telling you this is the
right person and
damn these lockdowns and oceans and
stuff
you'll figure out a way and if it takes
five years you know
chances are really good that you could
decide this doesn't make any
sense because of the geography and then
still not find somebody in that period
so
yeah um i'd say stick with it if it
seems right
uh what are we at zak
uh timewise minutes okay let's get four
more here and then we'll go to the next
uh
this hour but this is just a comment the
dog that does not behave in a racist
manner
would still be considered racist by
benefiting from an inherently racist
system
right now do we want to hold the dog
responsible for
the kibble that it eats blissfully
unaware
of the racism in the world lack of
awareness of a problem does not render
you
unresponsible for that problem in the
dog's case i'm going to argue that there
is a certain defense to be made
unresponsible as an ignorant word no no
um i was just trying to sound
woke i'm not experienced in it right
i'm not sure that that provides them the
advantage it should but
okay another comment in the past the
diluted were diluted
now the deluded are distilled hence
their power
um yeah that's how it looks if you
concentrate oh
wow terrible
so this question comes with a link which
i have not yet gone to
um are vaccine selection pressures like
in bird flu
possible um
[Music]
i wish i knew what that was a reference
to yeah um i don't
i don't i don't either
yeah it's a it's a paper published in
fibrology in 2016 but i don't have time
to
figure it out while we're all right on
here well we'll look at it and if it's
sufficiently interesting we'll return to
it
okay why can't i get my computer to
do this there we go oh that's really
bright uh is publish or parish a
contributing factor to the problem in
academia
scholars with scholars with nothing
interesting to say
instead publish and promote critical
theory which becomes a coercive
discourse
yes yep um yeah that's not the only way
in which it's
uh a problem but yes it's a massive 100
a massive problem yep
um and actually one more since two of
those were comments uh rather than
questions is it desirable or
and or beneficial to increase the world
mean iq to 130
why or why not can crispr or elon musk's
newest endeavor
neuralink a brain computer interface
accomplish this in the future
um yeah in principle be lovely to
increase iqs
well i guess
i mean i i guess i'm i'm sort of thrown
by like
iq is defined as 100 is the mean so true
yeah it doesn't like
the question doesn't doesn't we can fix
the question because
right but but then it does it just
raises the question of like what exactly
like what would be being raised
right like so you know if if people are
getting smarter the mean iq remains 100
but 100 in
2021 times is not the same thing as 100
iq in 1921 time so that is just that is
definitionally built into what iq means
how it is how it is how the metric is
how the quotient
of intelligence quotient is being um
figured how it's being calculated um but
smarter like what all is iq measuring
and what all would be increasing and
those are a couple of giant questions
and
you know i i feel like i could begin to
take a stab at answering it if i said
okay here's 12.
here's 12 things that iq is measuring is
trying to measure
is is stated to be measuring um
which of those things do you think the
world would be better off if we could
improve those
and i certainly i can't on the fly come
up with what those 12 things are
i got the one that i want to see
increase okay go for it extrapolation
careful extrapolation i want to see
people become a lot better at this
i'd like to see them become 40 times
better at this but double
would be a start right extrapolation is
is so much at the heart of what's gone
wrong the failure of extrapolation
so um i'm not convinced by
neuralink i am convinced that we are
software-based creatures and that our
ability to extrapolate has gone
up meaningfully across populations
between populations it's gone up
right over history and that means
something so this is possible
um but i don't think it's going to be a
genetic
intervention yeah it's not going to be
crisper right it's not going to be
crisper
it's not likely to be crisper and it's
not like
i hope it's not crispr neural link um
but how about
just not wasting people's time in
pointless counterproductive school
why not give them something this is
gonna this is gonna sound radically
sport game something educational i mean
that we took art we took the time that
people spend in school and we used it to
educate them
in something like i don't know
extrapolation
that's insane yeah that's crazy yeah
what is the evolution we're going to the
next hour now
what is the evolutionary reasoning
behind a problem like chronic dry eyes
do people who make money for eye drop
companies procreate more
yes are they well they procreate better
do they
um undoubtedly they have more
reproductive options based on having
condis into buying
uh i don't know eye lubricants or
whatever
that's ridiculous of course they don't
you don't think
a particular like you're basically
arguing that anyone is a successful
salesman
as better reproductive i'm arguing that
anybody who is successful
in the market all else being equal has
better reproductive equations so then
compared to all the other people like
not not not overall
right no i'm just arguing yes i'm
arguing that
there's a reason that people people
pursue resources
um yeah i think yeah chronic dry eyes is
um probably largely going i might i
think there are a lot of
modern hyper novel reasons for this um
but
my best guess i haven't thought a lot
about this but my best guess which would
be pretty easily tested
is that this is about our um climate
control and going back and forth between
um climate controlled and non-climate
controlled spaces and
you know the test for that would be you
know do people who either live
in um you know say in the tropics with
open you know flow windows where they've
just got screens on their windows and so
are never moving back and forth between
either heated or air conditioned and
outside spaces or are living outside
entirely
are they less susceptible to dry eyes i
i predict that they will be
so i certainly agree it's going to be a
novelty effect
it's almost certain to have an
environmental component i am also now
this week wondering about
changes in skull shape and other
musculoskeletal
issues that may affect the way things
that are supposed to be circulating
um are entering and leaving the skull
and things like that so
the possibility that there are things
about the dumb way we sit around in
chairs and
fail to do stuff that gives proper
feedback he said
well definitely sitting around in a
chair to the other person dumbly sitting
around in a chair
oh i'm in the room with him yeah there's
nothing there's nothing better than
talking smart about stuff that you're
doing dumb
yes um i don't know what this question
means i'll read it
as athologists explain opsinization by
aminoglobulin
do immune cell images compete comrades
selfish gender competition
resource competition so that last part
isn't wait wait wait
what options yeah opsinization
by immunoglobulin
so immunoglobulins are antibodies
opsin is a pigment
that is central to vision yeah i don't
know about opsinization yeah is the
process okay here we go
um here we have an
overview published in 1998 in the
encyclopedia of immunology
um that's not really helpful
optimal phagocytosis requires the
presence of both antibodies and
complement components on the particle
that's not helpful no no no no
really okay particles opsinized with igg
or igm antibodies
can activate complement through the
classical pathway resulting in binding
of fragments of complement components of
the particle
okay i get that actually um so
what was visible before i clicked on it
was optimization is the process where in
microorganisms and inanimate colloids
e.g liposomes and particulates are coded
with host produced proteins and lipids
immunoglobulin's complement factors
facilitating the binding of the
opsinized bacteria or particles specific
receptor molecules
present on phagocytes for instance
neutrophils macrophages dc's i don't
know what dc is
um so what they're saying so i so opsin
apparently does not refer
different totally different refer to
synonymous that's and that's
what it refers to is the encrusting
of microbes with immunoglobulins
so immunoglobulins are antibodies they
molecularly stick to stuff
the antibodies come in five different
flavors that is to say what's going on
in the tail end not the sticky end
tail end varies and that's like ig a igg
a and g are the different flavors so the
different flavors have different
uh implications um they're talking about
the complement cascade
which is a very interesting cascade of
molecular events
and the upshot of this is that the
what they're calling opsinization the
encrusting of something like a bacterium
with uh igg and iga do they say um
yeah immunoglobulins then results in
phagocytosis
by maximum igm igm so
the encrusting of the microbe is
triggering
these macrophages which are like in
amoeba-like
cells of yours you have these
amiibo-like cells wandering your lymph
looking for things that have been
encrusted and then ingesting them
and then digesting them they have
digestive enzymes that they then so
imagine you've seen uh how um
covid you've seen cartoons of how covet
enters a cell
right by uh binding the the as2 receptor
and then
uh being pulled into the cell well that
same kind of mechanism
is used by these macrophages to pull in
and then enclose in a membrane the
things on the outside like the bacteria
that have been
opsinized i now know the term and then
once inside in a little vesicle that is
to say a membrane bag
inside the macrophage then the
digestive enzymes which are also in a
little
bag inside those two bags fuse and those
digestive enzymes which are basically
i think they are very low ph
uh low ph meaning acidic
uh result in the tearing apart of that
thing so in effect the bacterium
is evolved to deal with the phs that are
usually found in the body and then the
body
exposes them to very low ph's in order
to dissolve the low ph
is is a feature it produces the cleaving
or the tearing apart
yes it basically is so
electromagnetically intense that it
pulls stuff apart like
imagine you you know you had magnets so
strong that if you
uh you know move them near a car it
pulls the door off right
um so that kind of yeah i feel like
you've done this
totally i have and so don't mess with me
because if you have
you still have the magnets man don't i
that explains what goes on in that one
corner of the house
and why everything else is constantly in
motion in the direction of one corner of
the house
so do immune cell lineages compete
comrades
immune cell lineages pseudo-compete
yeah okay so the difference is because
your immune cell lineages
have all but identical genomes they
don't have a basis to really compete but
they have an
interest as does your entire body in
them competing
pseudo-competing for their affinity for
pathogens so the way the process works
the way the process works is the most
amazing thing you've ever heard
and it is called uh adaptive immunity
it happens through a process called
clonal selection
in which your immune cells give birth to
immune cells that aren't exactly
identical to them and therefore have
different affinities
and those that have more affinities give
birth to more daughter cells that have
a variation in affinities and those that
have the most affinity give birth to
more and the point is that process
results in your immune system getting
really smart
about how to recognize an invader which
is how these vaccines work
right they trigger this system to get
good at
reacting to these things it's how you
get better from a disease that you've
caught and so anyway it's pseudo
competition because even the losers in
that competition
want the winners to win they don't want
to win if they don't have the right
formula
um they want they want the right formula
to win out
awesome
here's my attempt to explain why i like
brett enjoy
arguing it's like panning for gold in
rapids
people think you're wasting your time
and they scoff when you show them a
handful of flakes but hey
it's still gold
um yeah all right you accept that um so
i've got this
it's so yeah i can't see who's asking
the question so i don't know if any of
these are from
i'm taking it to say that that person
only thinks they like arguing and really
they don't like arguing nearly as much
as they imagine
the gauntlet has been thrown
um heather you once alluded to the
female analog of domestic abuse
which i took to mean the kind of soul
and ego crushing
meanness and emotional vampirism that is
the mode of female bullying
uh what are your thoughts on why it gets
a little attention and any advice for
someone who suffered through it
um so i'm wondering i uh
i guess i guess what this question is um
i would
i would zoom out a little bit and say
this
term that is widely used now which i
don't like but in order to
compare it to the right thing over in
female space i'll say
if you know toxic masculinity is way
over ascribed
but it is a real thing and domestic
abuse is a typical manifestation of that
and there are other
less gross manifestations but that's an
obvious one
it's you know a male typical form of
using uh power over members of the
opposite sex
given that that exists is there um what
are the chances that there's no
analog of toxic femininity in which
female you women use female typical
forms of power
uh to you know to have power over
the opposite sex um and
let's see the question was um
eco-crushing meanness emotional
vampirism female bullying um
why does it get little attention uh it's
more covert
it's more it's more subtle you know like
the way that
men tend to deal with things either
between themselves or
in service of you know trying to you
know force a woman to get something done
um you know in its toxic form is going
to be through
physical activity and that's easy to see
it's easy to describe
it's easy to call the police in and to
have them take
care of it if if you're lucky enough to
be in a situation where you can do that
and the covert stuff the behind the
scenes the using social pressure
and uh and gossip and
um and basically behind the scenes words
that don't leave any marks is
potentially very very powerful but much
harder to point to
much it leaves less of a trace both um
on bodies and uh in terms of just
in terms of the outside world and people
who begin to discern oh like everything
here
is kind of feeling like it all goes back
to that person over there
i think she's the source of all these
crazy stories and all of our lives are
kind of unraveling
it takes a lot of sleuthing it takes
more sleuthing
to uncover that that sort of thing
um so that's part of why it gets a
little attention at the moment it's also
you know we're just
just like we're not allowed you know we
have to believe all women and we have to
believe that no black people can be
racist and you know
we're being told we have to believe
these things that are patently untrue
um we're just in a moment where it's
harder to talk about um the ways that
that women also cause grief for the
world just like men do except you know
it doesn't look just like men because
men and women are different
um any advice for someone who suffered
through it
i recommend the arctic monkeys song
marty bum that's what i recommend
so i don't i don't know the song or at
least i don't know by the name because i
don't know well this is obviously a
stretch i don't experience this
phenomenon and so i
i don't need this song but it's quite
appreciation
that addresses this particular
phenomenon
i like the idea of vampirism by the way
i think that uh
it's a it's a good one but um anyway the
song uh
the song the arctic monkeys are deep
they're very deep band
and actually they're very um insightful
about all sorts of things including
sexual ethics and stuff like that
anyway this song is about internal
relationship
dynamics um and uh
anyway i don't know that it has any
advice about
what to do but it's certainly a
recognition that other people can see
the thing and have experienced the thing
that you're experiencing is important
right recognition that it is a
phenomenon
yeah right rather than you know being so
zoomed in that it just
it feels like you have to respond to the
details of it it's yeah you know
um so i mean listening to the song
so that you don't feel like you're alone
in the world um is that sounds like good
advice
you know i've i've written about it um i
think i
talked with uh with david fuller rebel
wisdom about it as well about toxic
femininity um
but i think you know it's
it's easier if if i i i don't know why
i'm assuming you're a guy
um to
want to just go hang out with male
friends and
talk about this thing and you know that
that can be useful
uh for sure but it also can lead down
the path to
um some of the toxic forms of sort of
uh mgtow and mras and stuff that that we
are also seeing something that i also
talked
to david fuller about back when we had
that conversation a couple months uh
years ago god whatever time um
but i would say you know find find
women who don't do that right like you
know
try try to have women in your world uh
with whom you're
friends um and you know it sounds like
you're interested in having someone who
is more than a friend as well
um there are plenty of us who don't
engage in that stuff
just like there are plenty of women
plenty of men
who don't beat on women right and
you know there are minor more minor
forms of toxic masculinity that don't
involve beating
and that's more common and there are
minor forms of toxic femininity that
don't involve you know
emotional vampirism and that's going to
be more common and you know the more
minor it is the more common it's going
to be in the population but
there are plenty of people of both sexes
who don't involve in the pathological
version of the thing
and they're worth finding
you are encouraging a serious deep dive
discussion based on dr guert's current
publications
he's the dutch virologist we talked
about in the first hour
who would you suggest as a dream panel
to participate
you know when we were first talking
about this just before the podcast
and you said this i thought i don't know
who should be on it
yeah i'm going to punt on this one i
don't know who should be on it either
and i would say that the big obstacle
and it's
unfortunately possible that the people
don't exist
right because the phenomenon
almost every field is stuck in one way
or another because of the
financial dynamics involved in how they
work right
what this results in is people either
succumb
or they're driven out and they do
something else and so
you would expect a field that was
hell-bent on saying dumb things
would have lots of competitors saying
smart things and in fact what it does is
it creates a kind of idea desert
because you need high immunity to the
nonsense of the field in order to
persist
in light of it and you don't get to
participate in the dynamics that
uh actually make a field worthwhile when
it works
right you know you get benefit from your
competitors pointing out what you don't
understand so your thinking gets better
over time and if you're
you know excluded as a crank on the
outside you don't get the benefit of
that
so anyway the point is i very much hope
that those people exist
they may not have the credential that
you expect them to have by virtue of the
fact that all the people who do
are yes participating in the system of
corrupt incentives
and so i don't know i'd love to know
what that list looked like probably we
could come up with them
you know you would want you know
naseem to leb types whose expertise may
not be
uh narrowly focused on the topic but
is a good generalist thinker who's
capable of spotting
neological scientifically savvy
generalists yeah without uh perverse
financial incentives yeah or other
incentives actually i want to revise my
answer slightly
the fact is none of this stuff is
unlearnable
right if you have the people if you gave
people the room
to acquire the immunological knowledge
that they need in order to process that
part of the conversation that's not that
hard to do what you really need is the
people capable of doing the
extrapolation and free of the incentives
but you'll acknowledge that that would
preclude them staying in their own lane
wouldn't it
uh yeah we're not talking about lane
stayers we're talking
we're talking about um yeah people who
don't even see lanes
right they're lane blind oh no
there might be something there i'm
elaine blind
yeah lane blind yeah actually lane blind
lane blind yeah i i have had bouts of
lane blindness
oh it's it's it's well when driving i
don't recommend it but
uh or you zack our 16 year old driver
i've never seen a lane i didn't ignore
oh boy
i read next question reads i read about
a study
that found that having a full bladder
makes you better at critical decisions
i'd like to see that reference are there
any other examples of situational
processing power
besides me feeling 20 iq points dumber
when a gorgeous woman walks past
um well first of all i
i seriously don't believe that finding
no i don't believe it at all no
the opposite if anything yeah my
thinking is atrocious when i really got
to go
um but i will say i saw this week
some others will have seen it too uh i
think i saw it on reddit
um a an orchestra in which every
member of the orchestra ate a habanero
pepper and then they played
uh i actually don't know what the what
the song was but
i was desert no but i was disappointed
that they didn't
massively screw this up these people
were professionals
they played they didn't screw up the
music yeah you're not talking about the
experimenters
no i was i was expecting a a
mangled version of this uh
piece by virtue of the fact that
personally your mouths were on fire
right that their mouths were on fire and
i cannot imagine
playing the violin through that well i
couldn't see violin being easier than
flute
well in fact there was an awful lot of
commentary about all the reeds that
would have been destroyed
in various instruments i don't know if
reeds succumb to capsaicin
i don't think they do but i think you
can't use them again because they're too
freaking hot
but anyway so that was an interesting
i don't think they played better but of
course an orchestra a really good
orchestra
plays you know very near perfect right
um
yeah and they're explicitly practiced
it's not there's no improv
um yes okay but situational processing
power but the flip side of this equation
yeah
is there are those of us who in a
crisis become very clear-headed
and i think it's a personality trait i
don't know what percentage of the
population has it but i
uh it is real and the point is
it is obviously borrowing from somewhere
right like
your emotional processing may drop to
zero
as you're trying to you know figure out
what to do about the the fire or
you know the sliding down the face of
whatever it is or
um but that capacity exists in some
i believe it is induced in uh elite
forces
and so that there's probably a way to
bootstrap that capacity
and it's not the same thing as having to
pee but um
but it's you know it's a neighbor yeah
yeah
there's only hunger game is try that
again
this is a tough word i mean you look i'm
gonna do it i'm gonna pull it off but um
there's only hunger gamesism and
anti-hunger gamesism
the only solution to past hunger
gamesist discrimination
is anti-hunger gamesist discrimination
um
yes
are we there i think so okay yeah um
let's see uh maybe two more questions
is there an evolutionary basis for the
uncanny valley
do near peer competitors pose a
different threat and warrant a different
fear response than other dangerous life
forms
related to neanderthals
um this is a great question yeah it is i
would say
you there is a question about whether or
not the unk so for those who don't know
the uncanny valley
is the observation that things that look
close to human without looking human are
actually repulsive
that there is a uh a sense
you know so there's a gap there are
things that look sufficiently far from
humans that we don't process them that
way and they're things that look
sufficiently close to humans but not
close enough
that are repellent that could be the
result
of a um
closely related species there have
certainly been periods in
human evolution in which there might
have been multiple
uh closely related species living in
close proximity
i doubt it pretty long time ago yes
neanderthals would be a case but that
was one part of
the human population that would have
encountered them and i think the uncanny
valley is a
phenomenon reproduced across populations
and so my guess
is it's about something more local like
the we we process a lot of stuff what we
call
beauty for example is at least partially
a result of us processing information
that would tell us
if they a developmental environment like
an in utero developmental environment
was
uh was a good quality environment or a
compromised environment and you can
imagine
that that might have a heritable
component so that is to say somebody
who had it rough in utero may have had
it rough in utero because the genes
surrounding the in utero
environment weren't good which means
that their offspring would likely face
the same disadvantage and that would be
a reason
that you would find us built to
reject such mates if there were others
so it may be that it's
the same process that causes us to seek
beauty
because it indicates something positive
that may be heritable or may
otherwise influence the well-being of
the offspring we would produce with
somebody that we would be biased against
a bunch of things that would
uh be hazardous uh and that this is
basically that phenomena
as things look less and less like your
stereotypical human there's more and
more reason to suspect something is off
i feel like there's a lot of places to
go there probably we should just move on
but you made me think of
both denis ovens and hobbits on flores
um a bit and also of what happens um
often with closely related languages
where you end up with for instance
in the latin languages take
spanish french and italian where spanish
and italian
um sound more alike right the
pronunciation sounds more alike and so
if you weren't
you might imagine that they were each
other's closest relatives and they're
not right
it's spanish and french if memory serves
and spanish and italian are more
distantly related to one another and so
there's a like
culture of a repulsion a fast evolution
towards incomprehensibility between the
more closely related languages
yeah although i think that one's a
little different i mean maybe it's
analogous but in that case i
mentioned the argument that you're
closest
if you're separating from another
population then what you'd really like
is for them not to know what you're
talking about yeah right so that you can
yeah uh compete more so within species
is going to be different
yeah yeah that's different but i can see
an analogous
argument um i just don't it's not a slam
dunk that it
it makes sense yeah yep um
two last one last question then one last
comment
trepidation about the long-term effects
of these novel vaccines seems
disproportionate
is this just based on the precautionary
principle
um yes and no i would say i don't think
it's disproportionate
obviously i guess this person is
commenting on our trepidation
do you think so i don't think our just
our trepidations are disproportionate
obviously
they'd be smaller but i think the point
is
once you have seen what complex adaptive
systems are like and how difficult it is
to predict what is going to happen
and then you see oh no we've got a
complex system
within a complex system within a complex
system so yeah to spell that out
you've got the population level what are
the dynamics of the virus and the
immunity
in the population you've got the
individual oh my god that's a biological
complex system
in which it is effectively going to be
impossible to know what a novel
phenomenon is going to do
when introduced into that body we have
to find out empirically and
the duration over which we'd have to
look is extremely long
and then oh my god on top of that you've
got this thing
is interacting with the immune system
which is actually the one system in the
body that literally evolves
within the scale of weeks to months
the point is that level of complexity
interfacing with each other
guarantees that there will be phenomena
here you simply cannot predict
especially given our very early stage
and even understanding the way these
things work
so what are the chances that there's
going to be bad stuff
it's higher than you think i don't want
to say that i want to be a cheerleader
for vaccines because we're so good at
wielding them and we're so
wise about what kind of harm they're
going to do but i know we're not
right so um three complex systems
three complex adaptive systems layered
on top of each other where one of them
is the immune system and when it goes
wrong
it's liable to be to create an
autoimmunity
uh or a cancer or something like that
that's a lot of hazard
yeah in such a situation we prefer tried
and true yes and
even then even then our point has not
been
don't do this our point is you've got
competing
bad situations you've got coven on the
one hand which is worse than people
think and you've got the vaccines which
are less well understood than we are
pretending and those two things now you
know
this is the situation you don't want to
be in where you have to make a decision
that you know you don't have any good
answers
okay final comment um an addendum to the
question about why we like unhealthy
food
um the most dangerous foods more or less
do not exist in nature like any
considerable amount of vegetable oil
which is inherently unstable
another reason that we have not evolved
a restraint
on um on eating the stuff that's
available now it is it's been created
for us so i guess that was that was
partially in i thought what what i said
an answer
yeah i'm trying to figure out if that's
actually different
we have concentrated that basically
you've got a system
in which there's no break because you
wouldn't encounter it in such
concentrations in nature that you would
need to restrain yourself
yeah right i mean we're not like this
with water right why because large
concentrations of water
are common and so the idea that you
would get to a lake and just drink
yourself to death
right no we've got a break that says ah
you're not thirsty anymore
right um you're done here you're done
here
and you know we don't have that for
something that would have been extremely
limiting right right like yeah sugar
that's just not
concentrated out in the world yeah and
but um i think i always
default to the honza but i think it was
the hanza um
among some other um african peoples who
specialize on uh finding uh
beehives finding honey and there is
gorging
after you get to honey but the fact is
that happens once in a blue moon
right like you don't end up with honey
every week you end up with honey
occasionally
and then the gorging happens and that's
okay it works
and also it's honey if you die you die
on that note i think i think we may be
done
yup um don't don't eat too much honey i
i didn't mean it
it's good stuff but you but you're not
interested think of it as a lake that
you should stop drinking
okay um well
that's it for this week i think that's
it for this week
yeah we're declaring it over a day early
um
actually it's not a day early depends on
how you count yeah uh
so um again um any questions that you
have to darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com um please consider joining us
at either of our patreons right now the
question asking period
uh for the private q a that happens at
the last sunday of every month
is open at my patreon uh for another
uh until noon tomorrow pacific time
um yeah
like that i guess yes yeah pretty much
all right everybody
ignore your lane
[Music]